Ami's with us in Columbus Ohio
hi Amy how are you fine I'd like to know
when you look on on lying under Yahoo
places like that on the internet and I
saw the million dollars is not enough to
retire on now if so is that true well it
has to do with how you want to live when
you retire okay I can invest a million
dollars in good growth stock mutual
funds and I can get somewhere around
seventy to a hundred thousand dollars a
year off of that without touching the
million can you live on that yeah I
never see those kind of returns
okay well I'm investing in decent growth
stock mutual funds that have normal
rates of return the stock market has
averaged eleven point eight percent
since it began and and so if it and
that's average some years is to some
years is a negative for some years is 17
but I'm just saying seven percent eight
percent will be $80,000 and the markets
average well north of that and so um you
know without touching the million now
again it might drop down some years and
it might go up some years but that's the
the average in a philosophical
discussion which is the question you're
asking me because you're reading a
website million dollars isn't enough
well it is enough if you can live on 70
or 80 a year and you're willing to
invest in good growth stock mutual funds
and you study a little bit you learn
about them you get with a good
investment broker you get some help on
doing the investing and yeah I think if
you can live on that then you should be
fine but it's a hypothetical question
it's a question that's a you know
theoretical question in other words so
the actual question is go to Chris Hogan
360 dot-com enter your stuff into the
are IQ the retire inspired quotient so
you know your your retirement IQ and
what you will need and you can set put
it whatever assumptions you want to put
into that and however you're going to
invest the money and then you'll know
what you need
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind